[Music]
[Applause]
I'm gonna tell you bring it in
[Applause]
look you guys know all the rules huh
tap out I'll knock out your own way out
of this cage otherwise whatever works
huh you show you one of those
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
little girl let's go
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
hi I'm Danny Rand my father in a way a
long time
let's go below here I'm Danny Rand guys
I just want to talk
welcome to Rand I left here ten years
old and a jet my parents I became the
lone survivor Danny Rand back from the
dead
why didn't waited this long to show up
how the hell did he learn martial arts
where'd you train come on
my father instilled in me a love and
respect for this company that has never
faded this is my home
Rand is my company this city is no place
for daddy no giving up no covenant
well many what happened to you why are
you really back here some bad people
have done on the inside criminals I know
what they are but they can do
to fight them we need someone with
special skills I've been training my
whole life for this this is my destiny
it's time I'm going with you
no you're not you need me
the change is coming down become with
you were meant to be
I am the iron fist how does that mean
okay what's that he says welcome to the
frickin guardians of the galaxy